the biden administration still has
no clear answer on blocking the media
from the border facilities
as these images from congressman henry
cuellar show
overcrowding at a facility our next
guest was responsible for dealing with
the media requests
during the trump administration former
assistant secretary for public affairs
at the dhs alexa wolterness joins me now
welcome
um so you say where there's smoke
there's fire
you think there's a cover-up tell us
about it what are they covering up
yeah well when there's a situation like
this usually the truth sets you free
and the fact that there's this media gag
order
tells everyone the american public and
the media themselves
that the fact on the ground is likely
much worse
than any of us know and that's the only
reason they're covering it up and they
want media nowhere near
any of these facilities what do you
suspect the conditions
are like based on the photos that you're
seeing here
that you believe this is much more
widespread
uh both in magnitude by how widespread
it is so
likely it's worse so if there's a member
of congress invited to a facility
they're only being invited to
the facility that has the best
conditions
that is least likely to have a any type
of political risk
right so if you're you get an invitation
from congress
uh you're going to take them to the one
that there's going to
everything's going to be in order so if
you're a member of congress
uh you know make sure you kind of break
out of this potemkin village
uh talk to the people that they're not
inviting you to talk to to get real
first-hand testimony
so yesterday um will interviewed julio
rosa as an independent
reporter who was going with a with a
congressional delegation
and they allowed the congressional
delegation and then they cited
covid as the reason they wouldn't let
julio in who's a reporter
here's what alejandro mayorkas had to
say blaming
kovid on on lack of access
let's not forget that we're in the midst
of a pandemic
and we are focused uh on our operations
executing our operations in a crowded
border patrol
facility uh where uh hundreds of
vulnerable migrant children
are located number one and number two
we're working on providing footage
so that the american public can see uh
the border patrol stations
yeah that goes to what you just said
they're working on providing footage
probably the best footage they can
possibly find
um how far up the chain do you think
this order to block the media
um comes from yeah at a minimum it comes
from secretary marcus himself
i think that this is a matter that
congress should investigate
and find out what information he has
that he's not sharing and also
explain why he's making this decision uh
and it can even go as
high as president biden himself right so
i'll tell you behind the scenes a little
in
crisis like this you're getting regular
briefings uh almost
up to the minute numbers and policy
analysis
and and we really haven't been getting
much information from the white house
and it just tells me that everything is
much worse than any of us know
yeah it certainly doesn't smell right
well there's senators going
this week a big a large group we'll see
if they can get to the bottom of this
media blackout
thanks for joining us very insightful
information